il n'y a pas si longtemps nous fêtons
noël en famille l'occasion de retrouver
ses cousins ses cousines ses oncles et
tantes qu'on n'a pas vu depuis longtemps
justement à cette occasion ma tante est
venu me voir en disant tu sais quand un
j'ai lu quelque chose à propos d'un
petit âge glaciaire vers 1400 du
visiblement à l'activité du soleil à
l'orbité de la terre tu vois je me
renseigne et du coup je me demande est
ce qu'on est bien sûr que c'est
l'activité humaine qui est la cause du
réchauffement climatique
et oui encore beaucoup de gens qui va
falloir convaincre en france et dans
d'autres pays
mais ici je ne vais pas vous parler de
ça je vais supposer que vous êtes
conscients du problème et je vais vous
parler de solution je montrais que nous
avons maintenant un cap clair pour
l'action et vous donner une piste de
levier à actionner en octobre dernier le
gie ac a sorti son rapport spécial
le giec pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
c'est un groupe international de
scientifiques du monde entier qui à
échéances régulières tous les trois à
cinq ans compile toutes les publications
scientifiques sur le climat donc si vous
voulez un rapport du giec
c'est l'archétype de l'état de l'art de
la science sur le climat et ce rapport
se poser la question comment limiter le
réchauffement à 1.522 parce que 1,5
degré c'est le nouvel objectif avant par
les deux degrés mais depuis la coop 21 à
paris en 2015 le nouvel objectif
politique c'est 1,5
est ce que nous dit le rapport du giec
c'est que si on est sérieux à propos
d'atteindre cet objectif
voici la trajectoire qu'il faudrait
suivre vous avez ici les aime
sur mondiale qui commence en 1970 les
émissions historiques sont très plein et
on voit que ça augmente ça augmente
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ce que dit le
rapport
c'est que très rapidement il faudrait
atteindre un pic d'émissions et puis
décroître noter la pente la vraie
rupture de pente décroît de décroître
atteinte 0 et puis même passé en tout et
je reviendrai un peu plus tard sur ce
que c'est à dire passer en dessous de
zéro pour les émissions alors ça c'est
la trajectoire stylisé parce que comme
je vous disais le j acques compile les
rap les publications scientifiques du
monde entier donc plusieurs modèles qui
ne disent pas exactement la même chose
mais en comparant tous ces modèles on
voit apparaître de résultats robustes
le premier c'est que si on est sérieux
il faudrait atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 il faudra atteindre zéro
émission de carbone en 2050
rendez vous compte dans 30 ans et un
monde complètement différent un monde où
on peut plus mettre de pétrole dans sa
voiture on peut plus avoir une
cuisinière au gaz naturel
c'est un monde sans carbone vraiment
différent et j'aime bien cet objectif de
neutralité carbone parce que je le
trouve vraiment intuitif sur vous
diviser par deux les émissions c'est pas
forcément clair zéro carbone ça c'est
clair le deuxième résultat robuste du
giec c'est qu' il faudrait d'ici 2030
dans dix ans / de nos émissions
dans dix ans ça commence à être assez
proche souvent dans le climat on a ce
qu'on appelle la tragédie des horizons
le temps du climat c'est le temps long
fin du siècle alors que le temps des
dirigeants politiques c'est plutôt un
mandat cinq ans voire encore moins la
ça commence à dire des choses sur ce qu'
il faudrait faire aujourd'hui si on veut
être sérieux
aujourd'hui installé une voiture
thermique même un peu plus efficace est
ce que c'est vraiment compatible avec
une division par deux des émissions dans
dix ans sachant qu'à tous les véhicules
qui sont encore toutes les
infrastructures qui ont une certaine
durée du bail
le giec ne donne cette trajectoire
mondial mais il a aussi analysé les
leviers de l'action et ses leviers pour
vous aider à les retenir
je les présente sous la forme d'un
acronyme que j'espère un peu accrocheur
cet acronyme l'ouest et des edf le
premier levier
le e le plus important c'est ce qu'on
appelle les économies d'énergie là
dedans c'est à la fois l'efficacité
énergétique avoir un frigo plus efficace
et c'est aussi la sobriété énergétique
sobriété ça veut dire ne pas consommer
une énergie dont on n'a pas besoin par
exemple les tableaux les panneaux
publicitaires allumés la nuit ou le
chauffage
quand vous n'êtes pas chez vous donc
d'abord utiliser moins d'énergie
le deuxième levier c'est décarbonés
l'énergie qu'on va utiliser ce qu'on
veut pas se passer d'énergie
le premier à économie d'énergie le
deuxième décarbonation l'énergie ça veut
dire utiliser une électricité fait
abbas renouvelables ou pourquoi pas de
l'hydrogène de la biomasse en tout cas
une énergie zéro carbone le troisième
levier c'est l'électrification parce que
l'électricité c'est le vecteur le plus
facile à décarbonés et donc on voit
qu'il va falloir électrifié beaucoup
d'usagers le véhicule électrique qui est
bien mieux d'un point de vue climatique
les véhicules thermiques
mais c'est aussi dans l'industrie
t'utiliser encore beaucoup de gaz de
charbon dans ses processus de pétrole là
on va pouvoir électrifiée et enfin le
quatrième et dernier levier qui est
peut-être le moins connu est le moins
évident je vais en parler un peu plus
c'est ce qu'on appelle les émissions
négatives alors une émission vous voyez
ce que c'est on allait chercher du
pétrole sous le sol du carbone en brûle
et le carbone va dans l'atmosphère une
émission négative celle inverse
on veut prendre ce carbone dans
l'atmosphère ils remettent dans le sol
et pour ça on a deux grandes
technologies
la première vous la connaissez très bien
c'est les arbres la photosynthèse
un arbre qui croient par la
photosynthèse capture du carbone le
tronc de l'arbre c'est du carbone stocké
ça ça marche très bien et c'est pas cher
la deuxième
qui est de plus en plus représentées
dans les modèles et on anticipe vous la
connaissez - je pense c'est ce qu'on
appelle dans le jargon les payx bex
c'est ça veut dire bioénergie avec
capture et stockage du carbone deux
étapes en fait d'abord on fait pousser
des plantes qui avec la photosynthèse
capture du carbone
alors j'ai représenté des arbres sur le
graphique en pratique cette les plantes
qui poussent un peu plus vite donc on a
capturé du carbone et ensuite on prend
ces plantes on les met dans une centrale
par exemple une centrale électrique en
fabrique de l'électricité et en relâche
de carbone puisque hambourg ruud les
plantes
l'astuce c'est que de mettre un filtre à
la sortie de la cheminée de l'usiné pour
capturer ce carbone est ensuite allé
l'enfouir sous terre
et vous voyez bien qu'on avait du
carbone dans l'atmosphère qui est allé
sous terre donc on a bien des émissions
négatives et ça vous allez en entendre
parler de plus en plus quand vous
prendrez l'avion on vous proposera de
compenser vos émissions en plantant des
arbres
ce que je veux dire ici c'est qu'il ya
quand même de grandes limites à sedex
pour les arbres se pose la question de
la permanence est ce qu'on est bien sûr
que l'arbre sera toujours là dans 10 ou
50 ans peut y avoir des feux de forêt
peut y avoir des changements de
politiques agricoles pour les bucks
il faut penser que en 2050 on sera dans
un monde plus chaud et plus peuplés 10
milliards d'habitants
les bex ça nécessite beaucoup d'eau et
beaucoup de surfaces agricoles
mais il faut aussi nourrir toute cette
population donc on voit qu'on va très
vite se heurter à beaucoup de
contraintes
et pour ça il faut c'est vraiment pour
ça que j'ai mis les émissions négatives
en dernier l'enjeu si on s'est d'abord
de réduire notre consommation d'énergie
de décarbonés et à la fin s'il reste un
tout petit delta là on peut faire des
émissions négatives mais on peut pas
continuer à faire comme avant et juste
compensé au niveau mondial ça ne
fonctionne pas alors là je
et présenter les grands leviers au
niveau mondial du rapport du giec et les
gens souvent après venait me voir en
disant oui mais moi à mon échelle
individuelle
qu'est-ce que je peux faire c'est vrai
qu'on a envie d'agir on n'a pas toujours
forcément les bons ordre de grandeur est
typiquement à ce même repas de noël
ma cousine est venu me voir après 10 ans
quentin je suis désolé je sais que ma
mère ma tante
je sais que ma mère est pas très
sensible à ces questions mais moi c'est
différent
moi à chaque fois que je quitte une
pièce j'éteins la lumière alors je sais
pas vous mais moi à chaque fois que
j'entends ça je suis partagé d'un côté
je trouve ça très bien qu'elle soit
sensible et qu'elle a envie de faire des
choses sur la question de qui est bien
autre côté parlé aujourd'hui des pins de
la lumière
ça montre qu'elle n'a pas du tout
compris les enjeux
ça c'est ce que je lui ai dit et
j'aurais voulu illustrer sa avec
quelques chiffres et c'est ce que je
vais partager avec vous aujourd'hui
regardons quelques émissions liées à nos
activités quotidiennes ou plus
précisément à ces activités ce jour-là
on s'était retrouvé au restaurant et
elle avait pris un burger pour fixer les
ordres de grandeur ou les apps en tête
mais voilà un burger ses capitaux on
s'était retrouvés à lyon et elle était
venue en voiture une voiture voit la
famille de quatre si on prend les
émissions paris lyon et qu'on divise par
quatre voilà ce que ça donne en fait ça
sort complètement du cadre vous l'aurez
compris on a 50 kg puisque dix fois plus
leurs gains voilà donc on voit que c'est
très important
c'est pas pareil ont tous les jours mais
voilà elle me parle pas de ça ne me
parle pas de la voiture
elle me parle pas du burger elle me
parle de la lampe
voilà ce que c'est ces 20 g en fait ça
n'a pas répète même pas c'est trop petit
bien sûr il faut se nourrir il faut se
transporter c'est pas la même chose que
s'éclairer après au restaurant elle
aurait pu prendre une ratatouille 200
grammes pour venir à lyon est aussi une
alternative si on peut se le permettre
c'est le tgv 1 kg 50 fois moins que la
voiture donc on voit qu'à l'échelle
individuelle
on a des leviers pour agir vite et pour
ça il faut pas connaître tous ces ordres
de grandeur bien sûr il suffit d'avoir
quelques guide pour l'action pour
l'alimentation
on savait que le problème c'est les
ruminants les viandes rouges et plus
précisément les ruminants vaches moutons
et tout ce qui est fruits et légumes
importés par avion abel manque qui
arrive avant tout les autres et qui est
plus cher mais tout ce qui vient par
bateau par exemple ça ça va ça mais pas
tant que ça si souvent mieux que ce
qu'ils élevaient sous serre localement
et puis pour les transports vous le
savez bien
donc on peut agir rapidement à l'échelle
individuelle mais je pense que tout ça
il faut le mettre en perspective sur une
année pour bien se rendre compte des
ordres de grandeur je vous propose donc
de regarder le bilan annuel moyen d'un
français plus précisément son empreinte
carbone
toutes les émissions liées à sa
consommation les voici
voyez que l'alimentation va représenter
à peu près 20%
ensuite on a un bon quart qui est lié au
logement ça c'est le fait de chauffer
ses pièces de chauffer l'eau chaude très
consommateur en énergie
ensuite on a les transports évidemment
avec la voiture au premier plan et enfin
on a tout ce qu'on pourrait appeler les
émissions grise tout ça c'est les
émissions liées aux biens et services
que vous achetez c'est les émissions qui
vont être produites pour fabriquer
l'écran de votre smartphone par exemple
et moi ce que j'aime beaucoup dans ce
graphique c'est qu'on se rend compte que
effectivement à l'échelle individuelle
on peut très rapidement divisé par deux
les émissions de l'alimentation on peut
se chauffer un peu moins et faire
attention à ça on peut essayer d'aller
aux autres au travail à vélo si on a la
chance d'habiter pas trop loin mais on
voit aussi et surtout que si on veut
atteindre zéro émission qui est quand
même l'objectif
au bout d'un moment les solutions ne
peuvent être que collective si on pense
que le co2 est un enjeu ça veut dire
qu'il faut mettre en place des
politiques de mobilité pour avoir
de transport en commun pour avoir des
bornes de recharge électrique pour que
les gens puissent se payer des véhicules
électriques
investir dans la recherche là dessus
pour les logements ça veut dire mettre
en place des programmes d'isolation
parce que tout le monde peut pas se
payer de faire une illustration parfaite
de son bâtiment
c'est pour ça à la fois individuel et
collectif
hier je voudrais finir avec un exemple
qui parle beaucoup qui est celui de
l'aviation je pense que c'est un exemple
qui dit beaucoup sur notre société
aujourd'hui
prenons ce français moyen bon supposons
qu'ils seront un peu plus que moyen
qu'il soit assez riche et qu'il décide
de partir pour les vacances ah ben voilà
ce que ça représenterait sur son bilan
carbone
c'est plus que l'alimentation et le
logement
sur une année c'est la moitié de son
bilan carbone annuel et
exemple qui pose beaucoup de questions à
la fois sur la question des égalités la
justice parce qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui
la personne riche qui peut se payer un
aller retour à ben ali n'est pas taxé
alors que la personne qui utilisent la
voiture pour aller à la son travail elle
elle paye la taxe carbone et la tva ça
fait réfléchir
et ça pose aussi et surtout la question
de nos modes de vie tant qu'on n'a pas
inventé des avions zéro émission parce
qu'on est nombreux à vouloir partir pour
les vacances découvrir des nouveaux pays
aller sur des plages superbes mais on
voit bien que cette envie se heurte à la
nécessité de réduire les émissions et
donc il va falloir réinventer nos modes
de vie nos habitudes et nos envies
aujourd'hui la mode c'est de prendre
l'avion et de faire le tour du monde
pourquoi ce ne serait pas à prendre son
vélo et faire le tour de france en tout
cas réinventer un mode de vie ça se fait
pas du jour au lendemain ça c'est clair
moi je pense que ça va se faire chacun à
son rythme la question c'est comment on
accélère le rythme et pour ça ce que
j'aimerais c'est qu'à la fin de cette
présentation peut-être ce soir vous
fixiez un objectif pour l'année
ça pourrait être ne plus manger de
viande le lundi
ça pourrait être essayé de prendre -
l'avion cette année que l'année dernière
voire ne pas prendre l'avion pendant un
an et enfin ça pour être d'aller
physiquement à la prochaine marche pour
le climat ou la prochaine fois que vous
votez de bien regarder le programme du
candidat avant de faire votre choix
parce que c'est vraiment comme ça
individuellement et collectivement que
nous pourrons atteindre la neutralité
carbone
merci
[Applaudissements]